[Musique]
j'avais je t'avais écrire des trucs mais
je le dirai demain
non alors c'est à dire à thomas quoi un
peu ton demain quoi vous allez vous avez
un petit truc non je l'avais juste avec
le bas fait loisy giulia mais non parce
que comme je sais la première émission
que j'avais fait je vous avais écrit un
petit poème jamais fait
oui j'avais fait approximativement 25
ans je ne me suis pas trop mauvais dans
l'exercice je n'ai rien d'autre
le melon bah oui c'est normal alors je
voulais une petite musique c'est à côté
de moi lui ça démarre mal a tenté dans
mon espace mon show alors
attendent aperçu il m'a mis encore
absent de tpm paix à la rentrée mes fans
se sont tous effondrés
leur amour était si grand peut-être
autant que mon talent a cité la bande
m'a fait du mal
même si la plupart sont normales on
appris de l'après midi d'hier ils m'ont
tout de même bien manquer sauf un mais
je ne peux pas dire qui c'est ou comment
j'ai cyril tués - aladin et je suis ton
génie aucun mot tu m'as voulu et soudain
de talent mais jaillit ya pas tellement
changé finalement
et puisque tu veut de moi dans
l'émission je reviendrai avec passion
vous l'avez compris c'est le retour de
kader mais cela a pris faudrait quand
même doublé mon salaire
[Applaudissements]
c'est par des loups
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]